today on the matt walsh show my film
what is a woman has been deemed
dangerous hate speech and banned by a
major internet platform but how can it
be hate speech to simply ask a question
talk about that also memphis is
terrorized by a mass shooter who had
just been let out of prison yet again a
democrat senate candidate's absurdly
racist rant is caught on tape and peppa
pig goes woke we knew that was going to
happen it finally did and with its
latest edition the biden administration
continues to resemble
more of a traveling circus than a
presidential administration all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you know that the byte
administration has recently announced
its plan to hire 87 000 new irs irs
agents in 2023 many of whom will be
bearing arms as they hunt for you and
your money most importantly you need to
secure your savings in a tax sheltered
account now and the good news is that
birch gold can help you do just that
birch gold group helps you hold gold and
silver in a tax sheltered retirement
account to protect you from big
government tyranny and also provide you
with financial stability for the future
plus throughout history gold has always
been your best hedge against inflation a
diversified savings can protect you from
downturns in the market if you have a
401k or ira that's underperforming as so
many people do right now just text walsh
to 989898
and you can convert that
into an ira in precious metals right now
birch gold group has an a plus rating
with the better business bureau
countless five-star reviews and
thousands of satisfied customers and you
can be one of them text walsh to 989898
and birch gold will send you a free
information kit on diversifying into
gold tax free take the necessary steps
to hedge against inflation today and
protect your hard earned money get your
free info kit by texting walsh to 989898
now
well the website eventbrite is a
seemingly straightforward and innocuous
non-political it would seem it's a
service where users can simply
manage and promote events or find events
that others have organized and that they
want to attend
as the website's twitter bio puts it
eventbrite is quote a global platform
that allows anyone to create share find
and attend events
that fuel their passions
well as it turns out maybe not anyone
actually turning point usa is planning a
screening of my film what is a woman
which uh the screening is supposed to be
this coming tuesday september 13th
at west kentucky university
they had used eventbrite's platform to
promote the screening but soon after
posting the event to the site they
received an email informing them that
the page had been removed for violating
the company's hate speech policies now
reading from the daily wire report on
this it says an email from the company
said
quote we encourage our organizers to
express their views and gather for a
chosen purpose
as long as it's done in a way that
doesn't violate our legal terms
we do not permit events content or
creators that promote or encourage hate
violence or harassment towards others
and or oneself
the uh notice of
and or ones that
that permit and encourage
violence and harassment against oneself
okay so you can't harass yourself or
other people and have an event
event they're saying the notice of
removal went on to say that the event
expresses views that are in violation of
the company's community guidelines and
terms of service
next the platform trust and safety team
advised that the event would be removed
the community guidelines for eventbrite
further promised that they are
quote committed to providing a safe
inclusive and respectful platform for
the organization discovery of live
events
specifically prohibited content includes
hateful or dangerous content or events
that discriminate against or threaten
any societal group or encourage violence
the section specifies content cannot be
hate speech hateful ideologies and
hateful activities that incite encourage
or engage in violence intimidation
disparagement harassment or threats
targeting an individual or group based
on their actual or perceived race
ethnicity religion national origin
immigration status gender identity
sexual orientation disability age or
veteran status
now of course
my film uh which you know if you've seen
it and if you haven't seen it yet go to
what is woman.com and uh rectify that
situation immediately but you know that
my film does none of those things there
is nothing in the film that could be
remotely construed as incitement
or as a call to violence in fact
nearly the entire run time
consists of me simply walking around
and asking people questions that's
almost the whole film
the film actually provides a platform to
many trans people
and many professionals in the so-called
gender affirming industry i give them a
platform i give them a chance to speak i
put a camera in front of them
now the fact that those professionals
embarrass themselves and collapse under
the most basic line of questioning it's
not my fault
nor does it make the movie a terrorist
act
or an act of incitement
i gave them a chance the whole movie is
me giving them a chance if they were not
able to take advantage of that
opportunity that's on them not on me
but at any rate this is all irrelevant
eventbrite claims that it's a
quote-unquote global platform for quote
unquote anyone to quote unquote create
share and attend events
so how does my movie fall outside of
that purview
would seem like a reasonable question
and yet the company refuses to answer it
we've asked them for clarification both
publicly and privately and so far been
simply ignored
this is the way it goes right
they won't even they they make a a
dramatic declaration saying that this
hit film is hate speech
and then when you ask well can you
explain that how is it hate speech
nothing no explanation
now any far-fetched hope that this
removal was a mistake you know
um as sometimes you you uh these sorts
of things happen with the with um
the big tech platforms someone's kicked
off or suspended and then they say oh it
was a mistake now when they say it's a
mistake it usually means that there was
one kind of rogue low-level employee who
just took it upon themselves to ban
somebody and then the higher-ups find
out about it and they correct it because
they don't want to deal with it and then
they say it was a mistake
any hope that that might happen here has
been dashed as more people have come out
of the woodwork announcing
that their own what is a woman screening
events have also been banned
apparently this has been happening for
several weeks now at least
the wake county republican party planned
a screening of the film back in july
only to have it removed from eventbrite
for violating its hate speech policies
supposedly there's a man named mark
early who sent me a screenshot of the
message that he got
when he tried to post an invitation for
his what is a woman movie night it was
taken down for allegedly running afoul
of the community guidelines
and then maybe most absurd of all
there's a group called no left turn in
education
and they had their own screening planned
for later this month
now in their case
they were planning to screen the movie
and host a discussion about it
afterwards
and a trans-identified person by the
name of sarah higdon had been scheduled
to speak at the event
and yet still the whole thing was deemed
hate speech so to be clear
a movie featuring trans people
followed by a discussion with trans
people is forbidden
because it encourages violence
presumably against trans people
meanwhile as one of the biggest
documentaries of the year has been
deemed too outrageous and controversial
for
this platform
they still will happily provide a forum
for all age drag shows
now you could go to eventbrite right now
and search for what is a woman on the
site and you're not going to find
anything except maybe some broken links
where events had been planned and then
were taken down but if you search for
events that bring drag queens
and children together
you'll find many results for example
there's an upcoming all ages drag show
in saint cloud and then there's the
union county children's drag story hour
and there's the drag queen story hour
with lil hot mess in seattle and many
other similar events
so that's allowed
but not a film a documentary
one of the most talked about and widely
viewed of the year
now when you uh
actually let me correct myself it's not
one of the most talked about
documentaries of the year it is the most
talked about one
now when you
hear about this sort of thing
as a conservative and and i think we all
have this temptation that you hear this
and you shrug your shoulders and you say
well that's how it goes of course
they're going to ban the movie what did
you expect
and that reaction is understandable to a
certain extent
but we shouldn't become so jaded that we
fail to notice the considerable
escalation happening in our culture
right now
the effort to push conservatives
out to the margins to demonize and
stigmatize us
these efforts have reached a new level
in recent weeks and this is not
something we should take for granted or
just passively accept on the grounds
that it's inevitable
a few weeks weeks ago we were being
labeled as literal terrorists for
talking about the medical procedures
children's hospitals are inflicting on
kids just to talk about it is terrorism
then of course a major podcast
conference apologizes for allowing ben
shapiro to appear claiming that his very
physical presence causes harm
and then as you know the president
united states appears in ominous red
lighting to warn that uh people who
disagree with him politically are
dangerous extremists and threats to our
very way of life our democratic system
and now we have a major event organizing
website that has declared a hit film
hate speech and banned it from its
platform without further explanation
now
the good news
about the eventbrite situation however
is that we can actually do something
about it
we can't stop biden from calling us all
terrorists until it's you know we at
least we can't stop him now when it's
time to vote him out of office we can do
that
but um
we have direct control and power
here we can
let companies like eventbrite
we can let them know that discriminating
against conservatives is not acceptable
if if all of us stopped using the
platform
okay when i say all of us anyone who's
if if you're a conservative or even if
you're not but you you you you still
claim to believe in free speech
you don't like the idea of big tech
platforms centering people
if you're in that category and that's
millions of people
if we actually used the leverage that
our numbers afford us
then we would have some power here
i mean a lot of these companies would
almost certainly back off because they
would have to
the problem though is that conservatives
for whatever reason are usually loathed
to use that kind of leverage
and then after refusing to use it
they become fatalistic and they say well
we don't have the leverage well no it's
not that we don't have it so we don't
use it
and that's on us if we don't use it
i mean what reason is there what what
good reason is there for any of us to
use eventbrite ever again
unless they correct this what they're
doing here and apologize for it
if they don't they've made it clear
they hate you they don't want your
business
and yet if history is any indication
many conservatives will just say oh well
you know i'll give you my business
anyway even if you hate me and don't
want it
here take my money please take it
if we start using the leverage that we
have
then we can correct a lot of things
that right now we think cannot be
corrected one other point um
i would have
little complaint about eventbrite or any
of these other platforms that silence
conservative voices if they were honest
about it okay this is an important point
if eventbrite came out and just said hey
look we're a left-wing company we're
only interested in promoting left-wing
events that's what we do that's our
business um and this is why we exist we
exist to promote uh drag shows and that
sort of thing and that's that's our
that's our deal
now if they said that
i mean i wouldn't agree with it
morally i don't agree with anyone
organizing a drag show or anything like
that but if they said that uh and they
said that you know
they only want to cater to half of the
available market
well
that's their business that's their
decision i suppose
but the problem here the real problem is
that they're not being honest about it
it's an issue not just of silencing
voices but of outright fraud
because they claim to be a platform for
anyone
but they aren't it's a ruse it's a ploy
and then when it comes time to
banish someone to the hinterlands rather
than admitting that it's a political and
ideological decision they instead make
defamatory accusations about hate speech
and incitement
that's the problem that's what makes it
also especially outrageous
and now it's up to us to decide
whether we're going to start holding
these companies accountable
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well you know and we talk about on the
show all the time that the left has
proclaimed an all-out war on childhood
having a will in place then is the least
you could do to protect your kids
there's so much else you could do but
this is a first step a will gives you
the power to decide who will raise your
kids should something happen to you and
your spouse without a will in place then
the state decides what to do with your
kids and you have to decide if you can
trust the state and i think you know
that you can't a will is about
protecting your legacy protecting your
finances protecting your children as
well it's about ensuring that your
medical decisions are honored when
you're unable to see them through and
it's about deciding who will take on the
responsibility of raising your children
or caring for a parent or grandparent a
will may be your only opportunity to
direct important family heirlooms
financial investments and also
responsibilities to the proper people in
your life plus it's an incredibly
easy and affordable thing with epic will
epic will bundles your last will living
will health care power of attorney hipaa
release and durable financial power of
returning all of that comes together and
it only costs 119 dollars for a single
person to create a will when you use
promo code walsh you'll save 10
all you got to do is go to epicwheel.com
and use promo code walsh to save 10
on epic will's complete will package
that's epic will.com promo code walsh
all right we start with uh
a terrible story unfortunately this is
a report from the daily wire says law
enforcement officials in tennessee
arrested a 19 year old man after he
allegedly recorded himself driving
around and shooting numerous people
throughout memphis the memphis police
department put out an alert on wednesday
night
warning of a black male occupying a blue
or silver sedan who is responsible for
multiple shootings
it was uh
not immediately clear how many people
had been shot at the time but now we
know that in fact the killer
ezekiel kelly is his name murdered four
people in total and injured three others
and again he was just driving around and
and it would seem right now shooting
people at random and live streaming it
on facebook and some of the videos are
circulating out there i don't really
recommend watching them i'm not going to
play them here but he's you know
babbling nonsensically and and shooting
people
so that's what happened in memphis
now here comes the part that you're
already expecting especially if you
listen to the opening monologue
yesterday
again from the daily wire the 19 year
old memphis memphis man accused of
killing for and terrorizing the city for
hours wednesday night as he drove around
shooting people
was let out of prison after serving less
than a year for an attempted murder
charge
that was plea bargained down to
aggravated assault
so this is attempted murder
that was committed a couple of years ago
and he was back on the street after
attempted murder
after police captured him in a stolen
car memphis mayor jim strickland said he
should have never been on the loose
strickland said quote
if the suspect served his full
three-year sentence he would still be in
prison today and four of our fellow
citizens would still be alive
records show the suspect was freed on
march 16th after serving just 11 months
of his three-year sentence
a new law strickland backed which went
into effect in july may have kept the
suspect locked up but it was too late
for that the bloody spree began just
before 1am and then continued pretty
much
for an entire day as he was going around
shooting people
um
so this this is outrageous on on
multiple levels because three a three
year sentence for attempted murder is
already absurd
but he didn't even serve that whole
sentence or even half of it
serves less than a year
and this is the second high profile
killing by a career criminal in memphis
this week
we talked yesterday about eliza fletcher
the uh the teacher mother of two
going for a jog
abducted and murdered by this
scumbag who already had other abductions
on his record and yet was walking around
the streets free
in fact there's so much violence in
memphis that reporters now are breaking
down in tears about it on camera i
watched this
uh from one of the local reporters last
night
and i know
memphis is tired right now yeah i'm good
i'm with you all memphis is tired right
now the eliza fletcher kidnapping and
abduction and murder
the other crimes we've had this year
leading up to this
it's difficult right now
bear with me
it's a very nerve-wracking night
yeah and understandable we've seen
reporters and people in media cry for
ridiculous reasons self-victimizing and
all the rest of it uh you know they're
criticized by somebody on twitter taylor
lorenz crying about that uh this on the
other hand is an emotional display that
is well justified i mean
uh
you're a reporter first of all so you're
so you're in the position of having to
cover all these horrible things and you
also you also live in this city that's
just plagued by violence people are
exhausted by it
even those of us who don't who don't
live in these areas that are especially
plagued by we're exhausted by it too
um
and there's a couple of points here
first of all
the current d.a in uh in memphis is this
is another soros d.a right district
attorney uh another lackey of soros
who's brought in there and uh is is
funded by soros and is installed
basically
with the intention of creating more of
this kind of thing
however
there was i believe a republican
district attorney before this one
there was a republican district attorney
that was in charge when this light
sentence was passed down to begin with
which only goes to show what i what i
said yesterday which is that this is a
democrat and republican problem
now the democrats are the worst
offenders obviously
they're the ones driving the car here
but republicans are many of them are
sitting happily in the passenger seat
and going along with it
the idea that we need prison reform
prison reform which means letting
criminals out of prison the idea that
there's a you know there's a problem of
over-incarceration
we hear this from republicans too all
the time
this thing you know tim scott and others
you hear them talk about the
over-incarceration problem
and they still will talk about that no
matter how many of these
incidents
we witness
somehow the problem is that there are
still there are still too many people in
prison so we've got a lot of violent
people on the streets and the solution
offered by democrats and
many squish republicans is let's let's
put more of them put more violent people
on the street
maybe there's maybe the strategy is just
to get you know you've got violent
people on the street and then you put
more violent people on the street hoping
that they'll kill the other violent ones
and they'll just kill each other
i don't know if that's the strategy but
if it is it doesn't work that way
because the thing about these violent
scumbags is that yeah they do they do
tend to kill each other uh but they're
also
cowards
and so they also like to victimize
people who are defenseless and innocent
and there's an extra absurdity of
letting people out of
prison after committing violent crimes
when you know that they're high risk
i mean you know based on the recidivism
rate already that like which is 75
so you know it's almost certain these
people are going to back in prison after
committing another crime
but it's not even just that you know
when you you put a violent person in
prison
and then you let them out a few years
later and they haven't gotten any better
you know and now they're going to start
and they're going to commit the same
crimes they were committing before
it's actually
they're going to be worse
okay so when you send someone to prison
they're going to come out on the other
end most of the time worse
because for all the talk about
rehabilitation
and i reject the notion that
rehabilitation is the primary purpose of
prison
prison exists to segregate violent and
dangerous people from society to protect
innocent people
and it exists to punish bad people it's
it's justice it's punishment it's
segregation and punishment that's why
prison exists
now
if you can also add in some attempt set
rehabilitation especially if someone
does have a sentence where they're going
to end up back on the street eventually
then fine that's not the primary point
but but but
that doesn't even have they don't even
try to do that
so they they throw these people in in a
prison cell put them in an environment
with a bunch of other
violent sociopaths
and let them kind of marinate in that
for a few years and then dumping right
back on the street they're going to be
worse which is why in the eliza fletcher
case
you know the scumbag there he went to he
went to jail for kidnapping and robbing
somebody
and then he's let out and then he
kidnaps and kills someone
so he's worse than he was before
and then we have uh this guy
whatever his name is ezekiel
ezekiel kelly
he goes to prison for attempted murder
and he hangs out in that environment and
then he comes out on the other end and
now he's committing actual murder
why is that happening well because
that's
people tend to get worse when you have a
violent sociopath
and you put them in an environment with
other violent sociopaths
most of the time they're not going to
magically get better
they're only going to get worse
which is all the more reason to just
keep them there
uh
let's see project veritas has another
quite damning undercover video or it
should be damning anyway this is of
north carolina state representative
crystal matthews who's running
for the senate
in north carolina
and here she is on tape revealing her
true feelings about her white
constituents and it might be a little
bit hard to to hear if you're listening
to the audio but we'll uh we'll go
through some of this go ahead and play
it
and it's heavily white
i'm not a stranger to white people i'm
from most of the white town yeah let me
tell you one thing you gotta know who
you are
[Music]
if you are listening to the audio
version i just want to get you up to
speed in case you can't quite tell
what's being said here uh so this is
crystal matthews the south carolina
state representative who is black
and she's talking about very explicitly
talking about her
about white people white constituents
and she says that um
they get out of control and you have to
treat them like children and then she
also says you have to treat them like
um
like pieces of s
no it is
very interesting i hope she doesn't have
kids of her own but if she does maybe
there should be a visit from the cps
because she apparently she puts those
two together
you treat them like children which means
treating them like pieces of s
um whatever that says about her
parenting skills it certainly says that
she is a raging
unapologetic bigot
let's keep playing some of this
so you know like for me all these other
people are tiptoeing around them and i'm
like
they'd be like
well i'm just gonna say something
yeah and that was my problem with bernie
because he was talking to an all black
crowd and he was afraid to say black
people
okay
so that was crystal matthews now she has
i i just went and checked again
to see if she's addressed this at all
uh maybe send some kind of tweet or
something even to make an excuse and say
yeah this is taken out of context
you know it's like as if there could be
a context that would make that okay
white people are pieces of s um
but she's not even doing that right
she's not coming up with any excuse at
all she's certainly not apologizing for
it she's ignoring it and she's able to
do that because she's she's a democrat
and she's black which means that the
media is not going to hold and she's a
woman so she's got a lot of she's got a
lot going for her identity identity wise
a lot of boxes are checked which means
she's not gonna be held accountable at
all she doesn't even have to address it
she can simply just ignore it like it
didn't happen
now it doesn't need to be said but i'll
say it anyway that that if this were to
happen on in the reverse i mean can you
imagine
a white politician
caught on tape talking about
her black constituents and saying
you have to control them like children
and and
treat them like pieces of crap that
would be i mean that's not the end of
your political career that is the end of
your life
your life is over
you're not gonna be you're out of office
you're gonna get impeached you're not
gonna certainly be elected in any other
race that you run in uh
you're not going to get any other job
and probably there's going to be a
fbi investigation
this would become a hate crime situation
they'd be coming up with criminal
charges for you
and we all know that right we know that
if it was a white person that's what
happened
and yet in this case there is no
reaction at all the media ignores it
no response
no apology
no backlash of any kind
and that is because anti-white racism
is
not only widespread especially on the
left and among democrats
but
it is the only acceptable form of racism
in america
it's not just acceptable it's considered
laudable
you know what this is not going to hurt
her chances
in the election
yeah i don't know what her chances are
outside of this what the polling data
shows but this isn't going to matter
this is going to have no effect at all
if she's a white person it destroys her
entire life and political career
certainly in in a second just like that
but for her it'll have no effect because
the media is not going to talk about it
but but actually if anything
it helps her
that's how sad this is if anything it
helps her
because it appeals to other anti-white
racists and there are a lot of them out
there
and then even among
white people
there are as sad as it is to consider
there are white people who are going to
be more likely to vote for her now than
they were before especially white
liberal women
so i guarantee you we'll check back
check the polls a week from now
she's going to be polling better among
white liberal women than she was before
they white liberal women they'll watch
that and they're like in in in ecstasy
practically orgasmic ecstasy listening
to a black woman say what say say that
they're all pieces of garbage
they can't get enough of that
because it's an opportunity to virtue
signal
by nodding along and clapping and saying
amen
and also these people they've got
they've
self-loathing they've been conditioned
to be self-loathing they really do hate
themselves
and so if they're treated like garbage
as crystal matthews says should happen
then that's uh they're into it they like
it
all right
speaking of no accountability this is
from axios it says a just listen listen
to the wording here
this is you gotta love this
a slip up
by social media giant snap allowed
leading democratic campaigns and party
committees to unwittingly tap into a
vast repository of republican voter data
to hone their midterm ads axios has
learned it was a slip up they
accidentally
were granted access to all of this data
that they shouldn't have seen
and accidentally
it it honed their their their ads i mean
they you they actually got access to the
data and used it in their ads but it was
an accident
they kind of they were walking along and
they tripped in a puddle and next thing
you know they had their midterm ads
which they had
designed based on data that they were
illegally accessing all by accident
that can happen if you're a democrat
right you can you're walking along and
you and you slip and trip into a puddle
of illegal data that you shouldn't be
seeing
um there's no indication that snap was
aware of or facilitated that data
sharing well of course not of course not
and the company said it's taking steps
to rectify the oversight but the blunder
underscores the sensitivity surrounding
reams of voter data that have become a
highly valuable political commodity
uh the snap snafu impacted data
maintained by both republican and
democratic data firms records show
though its use by political groups was
significantly more prolific on the
democratic side this is one of those you
got to laugh so you don't cry situations
um
you know more more of the double
standards of this if this is a
republican and republicans are accessing
this data
and they're
honing their midterm ads based on it
then this is a stolen election this is
the end of democracy but if democrats do
it it's a snafu it's a it's a mix-up
oops sorry about that my bad
and the thing that
offends me about this is how our
intelligence is insulted now the fact
that democrats are
um up to their usual dirty tricks it
doesn't surprise me
but don't insult my intelligence
much in the way that eventbrite is
insulting our intelligence
expecting us to buy this
oh it's just a mistake that's all
this is from e online it says penny
polar bear is very excited to share
about her parents for the first time in
its nearly two decade long run peppa pig
has included a same-sex couple the
moment comes during the episode entitled
families which aired on britain's
channel 5 on september 6th the short
scene happens when peppa's classmate
penny polar bear discusses her family
during the school day
uh i'm penny polar bear she says she
draws a photo of her two mothers in a
dress
i live with my mommy and my other mommy
one mommy is a doctor and one mommy
cooks spaghetti i love
spaghetti so this is uh
quite a lot of celebrating happening on
social media and in the media today as
peppa pig has has now
included a gay couple another one bites
the dust
another one goes woke i i can't say i'm
surprised by it i knew the day was going
to come
it is it is especially upsetting for me
because i have always found
peppa pig to be one of the least
objectionable and by that i mean least
annoying kid shows
uh most even taking the wokeness out of
it completely
most kid shows are
totally obnoxious and stupid and i i
can't even be in the same room as them
paw patrol that sort of thing and also
the the animation is just ugly and
lifeless and and
everything about it is is terrible
peppa pig i've always found to be
you know
tolerable it's got a little bit of a
charm to it and there are
there are moments here and there a
little bit of sly kind of humor for the
adults and not much of that but a little
bit but mostly it's just it's it's a
it's a seemingly nice kind of innocent
show for kids
and i can and i can be in the room while
it's on
without wanting to jump out of a window
but of course i knew that eventually
this would happen it can't you know
anything that exists for kids any kind
of kid entertainment kid content
eventually they'll get around to it and
now they have with peppa pig
now there are two moves
that the left always pulls with these
sorts of things very familiar and
they're already pulling these moves here
in this case where they say to any
critics like anyone like myself who
criticizes the inclusion of a you know
gay subplot on peppa peppa pig
what they'll say to us is number one why
do you care so much why do you care
why do you make such a big deal out of
it
and then the other thing they'll say is
that this isn't political is this
there's no agenda here it's just it's
just uh
you know they're just showing that gay
people exist
well
neither of those narratives are going to
hold in this case because of this
continuing with the e online story says
the inclusive storyline has been a long
time coming in 2019 a petition called
for the show to feature same-sex couples
so children at quote an impressionable
age can be educated on them
right because this is what you want when
you have your four-year-old watching
peppa pig you want them you want her to
be educated
on same-sex couples
rather than being educated on
you know one two three abc that sort of
thing
but you want them to be educated about
sexuality
says the petition
it went on the petition did excluding
same-sex families will teach children
that only families with either a single
parent or two parents of different sexes
are normal this means that children of
same-sex parents may feel alienated by
peppa pig and that other children may be
more likely to bully them simply through
ignorance
well except that first of all
single-parent households and
same
you know different sex two-parent
households are the normal
those are the normal households just
like statistically it's just a fact that
those are
the normal arrangements
in our society and in fact in the whole
history of human civilization that's a
that's a statistical reality
but
the fact that there was a petition
okay so you're petitioning and there
were i think there was like 30 000 plus
signatures on this
of people on the left petitioning for
lesbian characters in peppa pig
the fact that there's a petition means
that no you you can't you can't hit us
with the why do you care so much you
obviously care quite a bit you
petitioned for it you care so much about
the sexuality of cartoon characters in
preschooler shows that you you had a
petition for it
and we also know that the characters are
not being included just because that's
the story that the that the people who
make the show want to tell they're doing
it in response to a political petition
so
if you're on the left you obviously care
about this and it is a it is a political
ideological move
that's an absolute fact
given that it arises as a result of a
petition
and now you know
parents just have to decide you want
your kids watching shows
that are you know where the plots are
created based on left-wing petitions
the answer for me is certainly no
and we're rapidly getting to the point
where there are just no shows at all
that my kids can watch and maybe that's
not such a bad thing because there are
other things to do than watch tv
all right speaking of we're gonna stay
in the realm of television here this is
from the hollywood reporter here's the
headline
it says rings of power cast slam racist
threats against performers
middle earth is not all white
so they're claiming that there have been
racist threats
by p by fans you know by people in the
audience because some of the characters
in this new lord of the rings series are
black there are threats
they're saying that in the headline and
so you go to the the body of the article
and
you may expect that maybe they'll
provide some evidence of these threats
like what do you mean by threats are
there actually are there
pitchfork mobs showing up at these
people's houses are they are they
sending actual death threats
like we're gonna kill you because
you know this this character is the
wrong race according to us is that
actually happening well here's what the
uh the article says the cast of prime
videos the lord of the rings the rings
of power is united in speaking out about
racist threats that performers from the
show have apparently faced apparently
a message posted to the project's
twitter account wednesday strongly
condemned racist reactions to the series
cast members of color uh the statement
emphasized that despite online criticism
to the contrary author j.r.r tolkien
created a multicultural world in which
individuals from different backgrounds
and races could join forces for good
quote we the cast of the rings of power
stand together in absolute solidarity
and against the relentless racism
threats harassment and abuse some of our
castmates of color are being subjected
to on a daily basis we refuse to ignore
it or tolerate it the message continued
j.r.r tolkien created a world which by
definition is multicultural a world in
which free peoples from different races
and cultures join together in fellowship
to defeat the forces of evil
we see how they're retconning right lord
of the rings and now all of a sudden now
lord of the rings was a story of
multiculturalism it was a story of
it was a story of it was actually a
story all about diversity inclusion and
equity
now tolkien himself never said that
never used those words at all and
wouldn't have um never made any any
indication that's what the story's about
but that's that's that's what the story
is actually about they know they know
matter better than he did
now two things first of all
uh
i don't believe this
okay so
i'm calling bs on this i don't believe
there have been any threats at all and
the reason i don't think there have been
any threats because if there have we we
would see them they would show us
okay they're not getting death threats
because of the race of the characters in
the show that's just not happening
i invite them to prove me wrong but i
don't believe it and i have no reason to
believe it
and as far as racist harassment and
criticism that's not really happening
either
you can go online we talked about this
yesterday you can go online go to rotten
tomatoes you can go to where the fans
are talking about this and they are
criticizing the show but the criticisms
are almost entirely centered around
the fact that according to many fans the
show is boring they don't like the
script that's that's what it's about
but the second point is this th this is
clearly part of the reason
that these shows make diverse quote
unquote casting choices to begin with
because we've seen this over and over
and over again
it's the same story over and over again
they hire a black actor to play a role
and
people in the audience don't really care
about that they don't talk much about it
but maybe they they criticize the film
or the show just in general because they
don't like it
and then
the people behind the show turn around
and attack their own audience for being
racist
never providing any evidence that there
is any significant racist backlash at
all but just claiming that it's
happening
and then they attack their own audience
calling them all races
in other words
they are the ones who make an issue out
of the races of the actors
it's the show and the actors themselves
and the producers they make an issue out
of it
by assuming that anyone who criticized
the show must be criticizing it for that
reason even if they don't say so
the audience doesn't make an issue out
of it they do
as always
now let's get to the
comment section
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so uh just a quick update i i
did show my son the video of our our
little show-and-tell session here
yesterday and i proved that i did
display his artwork as i promised i
would and i can report that he was very
happy about that um he watched the clip
with a with a big smile on his face and
then um but then he became oddly intense
about it and actually he he lifted his
hair his uh his hands in the air
and threw his head back and screamed
triumphantly
and then ran out of the room
shouting back that he was going to make
more drawings for me to show
also so he didn't actually make the
other drawings because he got i think he
went upstairs and saw his hulk toy and
got distracted by that but uh
i don't know i may have created
a monster here pretty soon my whole show
is just going to be a showcase for my
children's artwork that's what the whole
show is going to be
because i also know that my other kids
because they're aware of this now
and so pretty soon i'm going to start
getting from the other kids why aren't
you showing my artwork daddy
now what am i going to do there i can't
say oh i'm only going to show i'm only
going to show his because he's better
than yours so this is this is where
we're heading
which honestly given the state of the
world and the kind of
news stories we have to talk about may
not be such a bad thing
all right this is from sean it says
there was an incident several years ago
where a first nation street thug
tortured a white miner to the point
where they had permanent scars on them
and the judge still ruled that his
indigenous heritage needed to be taken
into account for his sentence according
to the judge colonial oppression
probably factored into his actions so he
was almost as much a victim
yeah this is and i've gotten a lot of
messages from people in canada kind of
telling me like you don't know the half
of it when it comes to our our justice
system up here and how how ridiculous it
is
but um i have heard a lot of stories
just like this where
and this is why the people that went on
the stabbing spree up in canada
you know part of the reason that they
were on the street the one guy 59
criminal convictions still on the street
because he had indigenous heritage
which means that by law in canada
apparently uh you're gonna get they
factor that in as a it's a mitigating
factor
uh
and now they did another update is that
they they
found
uh the one guy
his brother
they found dead because he was probably
killed by the other brother
and then uh but the one with 59
convictions they did find him
but i think he's now dead too i have to
check on that hopefully he is
but either way if they found him took
him alive and convicted him
like the most he would do even after
killing 10 people would be about 25
years in prison according to canadian
law
but i wouldn't be surprised if he got
less than that
and also
the other thing is that like even if it
was true that
someone is a violent criminal um in part
because of systemic racism and
oppression that they faced as a first
nations person
even if that was true that that still
means that they're dangerous like i
don't buy that at all i don't buy it as
a mitigating factor i don't buy that
excuse
okay if you make a decision to be a
violent
scumbag then that's on you it's a
history of oppression even if you did
experience it it doesn't provide any
excuse for you but either way
the fact is that you're you're still a
danger to society it doesn't matter why
you did it
it's this one reason why i've never
liked the insanity excuse i don't even i
don't even like that
somebody goes out and kills people and
then they plead insanity
and the judge determines oh they they
didn't they didn't they weren't mentally
culpable they didn't understand what
they were doing
they're still a danger to society
they still need to be segregated from
society forever
arguably even more so now because we can
never trust them back on the street
again if they're if they can't control
their own actions buy your own
testimony
um
ruth says it's not the mat i fell in
love with the the flannel was what
totally sold me my life has not been the
same since the flannel disappeared
everything is turned bland and flat only
you can save me matt i feel like this is
getting
look i take everyone's emotions
seriously you know that i would never be
dismissive of anybody's emotions that's
not what i'm all about but i do feel
like this is getting maybe a little bit
melodramatic i don't know
um
chris sharp says according to our
justice justice system it's better that
a thousand guilty men roam free
than uh one guilty man be locked up
that is how they you know but but even
and we this is this is a an excuse that
we're often given for why we have to get
rid of the death penalty
um
they say that uh well you know it's
better to have it's better to have a
thousand guilty man go free than to
accidentally execute one innocent person
uh i'm not totally sure i actually buy
that
if that's true or not
um
i certainly think that that's that is
that's an argument that needs to be
defended and it often is not defended
it's just stated like it's self-evident
because the problem is that yeah to to
execute an innocent man is a terrible
injustice
but there are consequences to letting
the guilty men go free it means that
other innocent people are going to be
killed
graham says serving 20 years of 24 years
is significant to be fair that's over 83
percent that's higher than normal for
most offenders
but why wouldn't he serve the entire
term
okay the guy that ended up killing eliza
fletcher
yeah he did serve he went to jail 2000
got out in 2020 i think it
was but why would they cut his sentence
short at all
armed robbery and kidnapping
i mean why wasn't he given life in
prison i think is the first question
but
okay 83 percent of the sentence why not
100
that's never justified and the thing is
the parole boards are never held
accountable for this and they never have
to explain anything
lack of accountability is the theme here
on the show
well another long week is uh slipping by
without bringing home my giant walrus
morale is low outlook is grim
this has dragged on for
years now it feels like in addition it
has come to my attention that the johnny
the walrus plushie is officially one of
the fastest selling items we've ever
offered in the daily wire shop so
everyone else is getting their walrus i
still have not but i'm glad that you all
are getting yours while i take solace in
the fact that so many of my sweet babies
are receiving their own i also realize
that i've found myself in the precarious
situation in which my walruses captors
have discovered the monetization of my
suffering is uh incredibly lucrative for
them which i'm a little bit worried
about where that goes in the future in
any case go to dailywire.com shop right
now to take uh one of your very own
adorable johnny walrus plushies home
today also like most of you know last
month i released the one thousandth
episode of the matt wall show one
thousand episodes is uh it's a massive
milestone in my career but it's also
just the beginning if you want to see
one of the most important things i've
ever done in my in my lifetime you have
to check out my documentary what is a
woman you might not be able to find it
on eventbrite but you can find it at
whatiswoman.com it has more than 5 000
audience ratings and rotten tomatoes and
even five reviews from critics who were
brave enough to touch it uh just five
versus five thousand kind of pathetic
but at least they said something about
it just in the month after release was a
woman the daily wire gained more members
than at any other time in our history
it's the most successful thing we've
ever done as a company and i think one
of the most important as well just goes
to show that if you make something worth
watching unlike most hollywood films
people will watch in droves if you
haven't seen it yet go to
whatisawoman.com to watch it right now
that's what is a woman.com today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
yesterday the biden administration's new
monkey pox coordinator addressed the
media to provide an update on the fight
against monkey pox now when you hear the
phrase monkey pox coordinator your first
reaction is probably to laugh because it
sounds funny and that's totally
understandable it does sound funny your
second reaction is probably to wonder
why we need a special coordinator for
fighting monkey pox as of last week over
over several months of dealing with the
outbreak
the united states has seen one
yes precisely one monkey pox related
death
so
this is not an especially serious
disease it's not especially widespread
uh it's it's
not especially lethal and most
importantly it's not all that easy to
catch we don't need any special
coordination here we don't need anyone
to help us strategize how to avoid
monkey pox all we need to do
is refrain from attending gay orgies or
other similar events and if you do that
if you refrain from attending those
kinds of events already your chance of
emerging from this outbreak unscathed
and unpoxed will have risen dramatically
be that as it may the white house has
decided to make this a special priority
anyway and i imagine they're making a
priority partly because it's a disease
that almost exclusively impacts the
administration's most favored group and
also partly because the disease is such
a non-issue for most people and so
comparatively mild even for most of the
people who do contract it that it allows
the administration to claim victory
without even really doing anything it's
sort of like if they created a a an
asteroid response team and then took
credit for every day that goes by
without us all being obliterated by a
giant rock from outer space
that's kind of the idea there are many
political reasons why this position
exists and was filled by a man named
dmitry daskalakis
who had this to say
yesterday at the press conference
so i think you know this this virus
transmits through very close skin to
skin physical contact often in the
setting of sexual exposure but um there
are other mechanisms for its
transmission including if you touch
objects that individuals who've had
monkey pox touch or if um if you have
prolonged exposure to respiratory
droplets with that said signaling to
people um who are in the gay bisexual
other men who have sex with men
communities and also transgender people
who have sex with men that it's really
important to have awareness that's it
circulating in the community is really a
critical part of the messaging while not
generating um you know inordinate
concern and really focusing on the
infection as linked to an identity so
it's just an infection it's not linked
to an identity it just happens to be in
the social network
yes you heard that right uh the monkey
pox strategist is
concerned about people who are in the
gay slash bisexual slash
other men who have sex with men
communities
and he needed to include that last
category to encompass all of the men
who have sex with men
but are not gay now it's very important
uh just as we you know we don't want to
forget about
all of the people who
eat meat but are vegetarian
or those who fly planes but are not
pilots
or those who grab gather in groups of
two and two but not four i mean this is
all very important
yet the point about dasilakis that is
getting most people's attention
is that um he apparently got this job at
the white house after dabbling in the
world of gay bondage gear modeling
there's a photo that's gone viral of
dasgolakis
posing with his shirt open revealing a
leather harness underneath
tom elliott over at grabian dug up other
photos of colonel monkey pox in various
states of undress and donning various
leather get-ups i'll spare you the
visuals
but you can't help but notice a pattern
here after all this guy joins an
administration that also includes racial
rachel levine who's the trans health
secretary also passionate advocate of
child sterilization and castration then
we can't forget about sam brinton who's
the department of energy official
and dog fetishist who also enjoys posing
uh in uh in in leather online and except
in this case dressed as a dog or or no
well he doesn't dress on a dog he's
groping other men who dress as dogs
in fact while we're on the subject a few
weeks ago the national pulse
found something even more damning and
disturbing about britain reading from
their report it says a recent high-level
hire at the department of energy's
office of nuclear energy defended a
controversial gay prostitution website
with a track record of allowing children
to be promoted for sexual services on
the platform
this can all be revealed by the national
pulse in an article published on
september 15th on the pro lgbt plus
website advocate biden's latest top
nuclear hire dives into a defense of the
rentboy.com website which shuttered
following an august 2015 illegal
prostitution raid
rent boy is a colloquial term for young
men who have sex with older men in
exchange for money often under dubious
circumstances
the article followed department of
homeland security officials raiding rent
boys manhattan offices and arresting
chief executive jeffrey horont and
six employees on charges of promoting
prostitution following year the ceo of
the site which connected male
prostitutes and escorts with potential
clients was indicted on a charge of
promoting prostitution which he
ultimately pleaded guilty to
the u.s district court of the eastern
district of new york's indictment also
revealed the site's negligence regarding
underage sex work particularly across
asia it detailed how rent boy employees
described the age verification process
as a gray area as they did not always
remove advertisements when the
advertisers failed to provide
identification
now in spite of all this britain who
again
now works in the biden administration
steadfastly defended the underage
prostitution site writing quote
sex work disproportionately affects the
lgbt community transgender people engage
in sex work at a rate 10 times that of
cisgender women and many lgbt youth
engage in sex work just to survive a
2013 center for american progress report
suggests that lgbt youth are more than
three times as likely to have to have
engaged in survival sex
that's what they call it now the
dissolution of rent boy is more
dangerous than the website ever was the
rent boys weren't harming anyone but now
these young men might have to return to
communities and homes which have
rejected who they are and that's when
the real danger begins
yes the real danger begins when kids are
rescued from prostitution britain claims
this is about the sort of ethical
insight we might expect from a man with
a fetish for dogs i guess
so what does it say that these are the
sorts of people being
put in the white house
well it says of course that we're in our
late stage empire phase as a country
it says that we're the laughingstock of
the world
it says that we at this point are
basically begging for china to invade
and conquer us which i'm increasingly
convinced they could do with relative
ease but they may judge it not worth the
effort given that we're already
economically enslaved to them anyway so
what's the point
it also says that the by administration
is obviously not focused on solving any
of the problems
that americans are dealing with in the
real world they're too busy scouring gay
fetish forums for their next hire
and it says something else too this is
maybe the most important point it says
that the left
is no longer interested
in making any effort
to mask their depravity and extremism
and degeneracy
they're now putting it on full
display for all of us to see
and while that's quite disturbing to
have to witness
and it's also a scary thing that
these people are in charge of the
country
it's also good that they're putting it
out there for us to see now
and giving us a choice to make
is this what we want
do we want people running the country
who
you know engage in dog
fetishism because that's what the left
is
that's what the left has been for many
years
the difference is that now they're out
in the open about it
yet even still i must say that the
monkey pox coordinator
is today canceled
and we will leave it there for
this portion of the show as we move over
to the members block and uh hope to see
you there if we don't talk to you
tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you